perfect trick shot sometimes so perfect
you wonder if they're even real now if
you saw the last video I took a
devastating defeat to Jordan Allen and
now he's out literally sitting on a
beach in Bora Bora resting on his
Laurels well guess what I'm not gonna
let that stop me from training I've come
in from Texas to train with one of the
gurus in the studio Sam Gorski we have
to rebuild you today
bye not using the most complex of trick
shots but by using the most simple of
trick shots the trick shots that you
grow up with you see we're going back to
basics if you can beat me then I will
gift you one thing that I know will
destroy any VFX artist in a trick shot
challenge a secret to magical item that
will completely ruin Jordan's days as
you'll see here each trick is a test of
skill but also a test of your own mind
let's take a look here what do we see
what is this we have a replica of you
and of course on your shoulder is but a
chip if you're going to defeat Jordan
the first trick shot you must do is snap
a coin and destroy that chip on your
shoulder next we bring it back nearby at
the middle school a football field you
fold up a small paper football you take
it you flick it through the goal posts
you really think these child's games are
going to help me defeat Jordan Allen if
you can't defeat him after like
practicing these simple moves then who
can third round three you are also
making an investment in yourself in the
future just like this quarter here we
will be rolling it down into this little
piggy bank you are investing in yourself
by going through these challenges how
could we not include a bottle flip we
will be flipping this bottle into an
array of other bottles making it
incredibly difficult but this is more
than a bottle flip as the bottle flip
represents the first truly cool trick
shot that anyone can do to impress their
friends at a young age it brings us to
the next one a landing strip you must
successfully land using a paper airplane
will throw them from the top of the
stairs down to here also it's very
important as we see there's a
progression of age airplanes only flown
by adults meaning this is the adult
stage trick shot it has to land
perfectly within the landing strip I
have a feeling this is going to be the
most difficult one is that it
there's one final trick shot look at the
very first video on dude Perfect's
Channel Growing a basketball behind your
head and into the hoop that is the
truest of trick shots and let's not
forget if you say dude or perfect during
this challenge you must complete a
classic beer pong shot like always
everything on my end is set are you
ready Jake
oh I'm ready I was born ready
all right enough talking are you ready
three two one trick shot okay here we go
let's see what happens when I hit this
button this first one's gonna be simple
because I have a little bit of an
advantage I'm not simulating two fingers
going I'm just simulating that initial
throw also make sure I'm not going
faster than what's humanly possible I
could turn into a bullet but then I feel
like that would be Unbecoming
come on baby come on I do want to get
this chip off my shoulder I can't really
start my journey
[Music]
oh that was so close negative 1 000 how
about that
oh I'm I'm already almost done
oh let's see oh look how close that is
so close to hitting it see I have the
advantage on this first one I need like
increments
oh oh there it is boom that's a chip you
know what the chip I got it you got it
already sorry Jake but this one is mine
all right let me bake that simulation
oh come on I hit it I hit it but it
didn't break I gotta break that chip
wanna see a sweet lunch trick shot well
today's sponsor is cook unity and guess
what they're a chef to Consumer platform
yeah that's right oops okay actually
you're supposed to take the film off but
the point is is that cook Unity is
actually a platform that delivers you
freshly prepared food from a diverse
wide range of chefs and it's really cool
because they're actually made fresh in
micro kitchens not like Giant food
processing facilities so obviously the
cook Unity foods are made with real
ingredients and there's humanely raised
meat and organic ingredients when
possible plus also if you look at these
recipes it's a really diverse set of
flavors like Filipino spaghetti
bolognese honey butter chicken and I've
never had a shrimp Caesar salad but this
one looks pretty great two of my
favorite things combined and here's the
best thing these things are fully cooked
all you got to do is heat it up it's
incredible and it's all shipped in a
recyclable container so boom no dishes
no cleanup if that ain't a lunch trick
shot I don't know what is not to mention
you can customize your subscription
however ever you want as little as four
meals even up to 16 meals per week it's
crazy if you have some sort of dietary
restriction don't like meat only like
meat the point is is that there actually
is a variety of options you got vegan
you got your paleo you got gluten-free
so whatever style cuisine you like they
got it also you can stop you can cancel
you can pause you can skip a week it's
completely flexible and up to you
so if you guys want to try some of these
for yourself you can go to cookunity.com
Corridor crew and try them out for
yourself or click the link in the
description and use that Corridor crew
50 coupon code to get 50 off your first
order yeah this looks like some dang
good chicken I mean look this isn't a
product shop this is just a humble man's
plate of food here that I've warmed up
for lunch obviously the site might not
match the flavor that I'm experiencing
but I can tell you it's fantastic if we
bring this down there fuel myself up to
beat Jake effortlessly
why does it say ponies right here that's
because Sam and I both went to
Stillwater High School our mascot was
the ponies Nico went there too this is a
representation of bringing me back to my
childhood the ponies I'm here I'm at the
10 yard line I'm gonna kick field goal
oh that was so close let's see if I can
do this uh authentically by smacking it
first I'm actually having an object
hitting
okay something's wrong look at that
weird glitch it goes through it oh yeah
and it was like meow that's not good
this was a class favorite to play this
every day bro
yes
Sam I've broken down my childhood and
I'm ready to begin my journey can you
believe it oh Isn't that cool oh wow
great to hear
all right Sam I'm moving on I will not
let
spinning
it's time to start making an investment
in myself one quarter at a time
[Music]
oh
that was a little high
let's do this oh
yeah that's going through yeah well
that's going through all right we got it
all right saving
[Music]
quarters Jordan quarter
this next one is going to be incredibly
hard because there's like Mexican
jumping beans in the quarter
that's terrible that's terrible you have
all the quarters
oh
yeah
I'm on fire right now come on Jordan
how's it going over here Sam oh great
you know we just tried wind yet you know
what what if I just said hey you know a
little Queenie hey just go over here a
little bit Yeah woohoo oops it's gonna
have to roll more than that all right
well I'm gonna go to the water bottle
flip now all right cool have fun losing
later yeah well I don't know about that
God damn it I really don't want to give
them the secret item Blood of My Blood
okay this is the lifeblood of humanity
if I can restore this to its proper
position then I can restore Humanity
oh all right well this is gonna take a
while I gotta get it higher
did I just make it on accident no it
didn't make it oh no it literally hit
the edge
oh my God it's yeah it's hitting it
perfectly but flat
let's move you over a little bit baby
feeling good about this
oh it's losing stability right at the
end oh
oh do you see how that's really close
oh
they're about there there how about that
oh come on baby oh you got to score oh
got him hey baby oh you got it they're
getting it now Nick piece of cake all
right time to flip this thing straight
in there on the first try Oh wrong way
how about this way
there we go
I was too calm last game I I was too
focused I gotta I gotta keep my emotions
in it a little bit
[Music]
that's what I'm learning here am I
better today than I was yesterday that's
the trick baby time to fly baby
you see how it has an extra fold here
that helps with lift also there's a
technique with these airplanes you don't
want to throw it at your target you want
to throw it so that the nose isn't
pointed down but that's pointed slightly
up so it can catch a little bit of lift
oh oh very close I'm already really I'm
very close
um let's do a little more spin
wait did I just do it perfectly I did
what did you just say I just did it yeah
but what did you say what was the second
thing you just said shut up Sam you need
to take a penalty shot you said the word
do it
okay easy
easy
there oh there it is
oh that one I had I had hopes and dreams
for that one the thing with these ones
is it's the unpredictability each each
plane is different and that's the
difficulty of this you know I feel like
oh
come on that was right on man airplane
right up here all right boom let's get
some velocity so Cinema 40s physics is
great because it actually has some lift
and drag in it so I can actually get
this little plane to float aerodynamics
we're going to give it about 80 lift
let's see how it goes all right
oh oh my God took a nose dive so right
now it's stopping a little short to make
sure I'm going the right direction all
right I gotta get serious Sam's on the
planes as well
it's not about me versus the other
person it's about me versus me this is
an ancient thing that I knew already as
a track runner it was never about trying
to beat the person in front of you it
was trying to beat yourself
see what I mean where does that where's
that Ding Dang plane
it's going full ham it's only got one
percent lift and it's doing that crazy
stuff come on stupid plane
what a beautiful flight wow I've not
seen a beautiful flight like that since
92. let's take a look at this airplane
and diagnose things what is bad about
this design nothing because I can easily
get it to land on the table boom like
boom yeah that's that's that but that's
not simulating the flight path no of an
airplane
go go go go go go go go go
ah technically I landed it but you need
to land it on the runway you would not
be allowed to be a pilot if you did that
perhaps drag let's add some drag
two-sided aerodynamics let's see what
that does too yeah oh oh my God it got
so close to landing on it and then
curved off
I'm gonna get one of them all right you
know what we're gonna need more steps
per frame
did it oh it's on it's gotta be totally
on the runway we're good baby all right
uh so anyways I'm gonna get lunch
wait did you get it oh yeah oh yeah
let me see zoom in on that enhance
enhance its final position zoom in
enhance dude man he got it the
inconsistency of the physics always gets
me for the sake of Saving Face and
moving on let's be honest
my lift I know Jordan is more of like a
squat right now and I'm not very happy
as you can see
let me let me just take a moment let's
take a moment to appreciate Jake here
the amount just just watch how it
beautifully Glides
that's it
is that are we counting that Sam
honestly that was beautiful
[Music]
Jake this is really important you're
throwing this backwards right yes
backwards how am I supposed to do this
you need to do this facing backwards
yeah I'm backwards did you hear
backwards you need to you need to set
your parameters hit it turn around look
at your monitor reset parameters hit
turn around look at your monitor just
like I'm doing
it's possible you need to do that before
you start
all right already we got some nice lift
there all right so we got that uh let's
double check our directions here all
right
wait this makes no sense why I'm turning
around
okay no the little a little low
[Music]
getting closer
oh that's the rim baby
oh too high too high too high too high
it went through something yeah it's okay
no like it's going up into the deck um
oh come on oh where are we where are we
at
[Applause]
e
whoa goodbye chippy goodbye chippy
oh
sorry Sam better luck next time buddy
I'm coming for you I'm waiting for you
to get back right here to this studio in
Los Angeles so I can go head to head ah
Sam yeah Jake hey good job out there I'm
sorry you lost no I'm not Incredibly
Close you taught me something here
that's more important than magical items
and that's more important than winning
and that's how to play as myself and
that's something that I didn't know how
to do in the last two games so thank you
for that of course I'm excited to give
you
something as a visual effects artists I
thought to myself what would the worst
thing to recreate in a trick shot be
well let's say it's a matter of
perspective
it's another box and inside this box is
the actual secret thing
yes
I was Amir going to help me defeat
Jordan well it's quite simple actually
the trick shot that you devise using
this mirror will he hold a mirror like
you or will he have to do a trick shot
using a digital computer generated
mirror constraining your perspective
through that mirror real-time Ray
tracing rendering we'll see I don't know
what's at his disposal but worst case
scenario we have one of those thank you
Sam this is a very educational moment
and I really appreciate this I'll take
it with me in my future endeavors it's a
great day for Humanity
all right man soak it up man soak it up
[Music]
wouldn't you like to know a little more
about the story
where are we where are we at I beat Jake
by a full 10 seconds
[Music]
did it
[Applause]
[Music]
I gave Jake exactly what he needed which
is the confidence to beat Jordan
look I love winning it's very fun but I
also like seeing Jordan lose
[Music]
Jake has put far more work into this
than I have this is his story we are in
Jake's story right now and I'm not going
to ruin it I I wanted him to walk away
with this with the ability to take out
Jordan and he has that
no Wally future for me I want my kids to
know the feeling of Landing a real trick
shot
before
they learn to do it like I do